Elon Musk wants to do the podcast right
back here on the feud really yeah
message me can I come in as your as your
co-host no I'll just listen like
everybody else that's really cool yeah
it should be interesting yeah he wants
to get his model three up to some high
level production and once it's done the
time away no model three tests on the
model three
yes he's close concentrating on yeah
he's just yeah once he's got that they
just delivered their first 1000
flamethrowers this weekend yeah what's
up with that to do it just to see what
happened like I just buy one and you
couldn't do it take it out back you
couldn't do it as a flamethrower so he
named it not a flamethrower so what it's
called yeah it's called not a
flamethrower it's that way you can
company not a flamethrower okay but
people get killed by these things wait a
minute this is your much mariachi band
playing it's the big unveiling that's
what you picked them up is that real yes
sir go back up to that photo of the
flamethrower Jesus Christ look at that
[ __ ] thing pretty cool oh my god
that's amazing
yeah I'm just gonna buy propane maybe to
refill it and connect it and it seems
like it's gonna cause a housewife what's
the purpose of that - when you when your
enemies come close no matter bullets
yeah you hide behind the couch and
warfare and the movie alien yeah yeah
they have flamethrowers yeah you need to
burn them instead of shoot them because
it's a you're on a spaceship if you live
on a spaceship oh right right what are
you gonna do with the flamethrower my
boyfriend asks me and that's her that's
the author out there blasting yeah it's
alia she didn't doesn't even have the
stock against her [ __ ] armpit she
doesn't even know what she's doing
look where she's got the stock I don't
know parable technique tuck that into
your arm honey yeah but there's not a
lot of kickback I don't leave throw rock
you do that like like you're a goddamn
professional you exercise with trigger
control - what about its internal
discipline what about all those tunnels
well I didn't realize how many tunnels
he wants
dude he wants us he's doing everything
he's making flamethrowers yeah he's
making these gigawatt factories these
gigantic batteries that are powering
Australia yeah I mean Nevada he's a very
very unusual human being it's amazing
it's just the walls just do it you get
an idea just do it she does not know how
to handle that gun somebody saw told me
they saw him they saw him speaking and
about the tunnels mm-hmm and because
he's got to get approval like there's
different things he's got to get past
and he doesn't just want a tunnel like
from here to LAX
he wants multiple tunnels so like if
you're going to the United Terminal it
takes you right there if it goes to the
American one it takes you there it's
gonna be a whole like ant farm of
tunnels all through the city what
happens if we get an earthquake what
happens if there's tsunami do those
things fill up with water and is
everybody drown inside those tubes
it says the tunnels are weatherproof mmm
it means when it rains yeah that's yeah
what about an earthquake I don't think
earthquake is weather mmm no I know
looking to see if they have any I've
been getting claustrophobic lately ooh
why